có mắt, có đồng chiến được trong khi hợp đảng dịp này. Có những người chực tiếp thông ra kháng thiến
phục vụ chiến đấu có người chưởng thành trong các tơ quan của đảng nhận nước được lượng
bú trang, mặt trạch, đoạn thẻ, đều phương, cơ sợ. Có người cả đời em thầm cũng yến ở những
bị chiến, bị chiến, những rất phải quan. Dù ở đâu, làm gì? Thế không chỉ đều có một điều chung
sức tăng tin trọng. Nó là lòng tệ đối chúng ta hiểu đàn, quý tổ quốc với nhật rất luôn là lấy chung,
lên lấy dân, rử dình, hẩm chất xanh sự, khí tiếp của người đàn quyêm cộng sản.
Hó thể chức phục công việc ngoan cánh mỗi người khác nhau, những người y tờ thì đều thông ra,
nó là phục sự tổ quốc phục, hình rất chính nghiên điều đó, nó là mên sự cao quý của huyều
tấm mùiều không chỉ được gấm trên người cao, nó không một chính tần, điều đó bẹt, điều đàn được khách sâu trong lòng đàn.
Trong lòng, những rất, những một biểu tệ của liêm tìm của niết tệ của cũng oiến và chắc hiệp, điều gần.